hey I'm Tiffany Smith I'm Christian hora
and our guest is the host of real kids
dan for all can we take that again I
think it could gone better who broke her
foot Dan thanks for joining us on thank
you for having me I think this would go
well I love all movies all of them all
the movies I spent a lot of time movie
researching what movie is mr. smart from
stars real star trail I missed that one
well I bet you haven't seen as many
movies as Tiffany I bet I have a good
transition because no other movie show
puts their butts in their line like we
do when it comes to box-office wagers
you the audience you decide what we are
going to do when we lose TIFF you know
what it's like when we lose this week's
weekly wager was on minions so Dan do
you wanna help South Christian you
guessed that minions would make 95
million dollars Tiffany you guys would
make 105 it actually made 115 that means
Tiffany is the winner and the punishment
this week was tweeted in the loser of
this week's bet should have to do the
entire show in slow motion is that even
possible yes put him in slow no you
can't move on to the next topic this
week ant-man comes out starring Paul
Rudd and Michael Douglas and I'm really
excited to see how this movie is gonna
fit into the whole Marvel Cinematic
Universe so why don't we check out a
clip
I need you to be the ant-man
I do not know where I'm Gosling was in
it I'm gonna say that I think ant-man is
gonna make like 79 million and since
Christian is stuck in slow motion dan
you get to make his later I like him
getting punished so I'm gonna say like
20 bucks make sure guys is the hashtag
losers should used on Twitter Facebook
and in the comments below on YouTube and
we will definitely stick to whatever
punishment you guys send it can he stay
that way the rest of the show absolutely
he lost the bet so he has severely
they're saying that sometimes we shoot
remote locations and if Christians in
slow motion it might be awkward
Christian oh he's still in slo-mo
Christian wanted to give these to you
guys as a tree but he lost him bet so he
has to be a slow-motion so I get to be
the giver of gifts open him up what was
it like don't worry he's just so upset
those are pretty good impression makes
them feel a little bit better
so I guess that means we have to take
them out of I prefer you in slow motion
you look like a minion very true you
know you could have brought these
headlines a lot faster headlines this
past weekend San Diego Comic Con had a
lot of exciting and surprising moments
however I couldn't get my head or heart
away from what they did at Star Wars
when he came out you can tell Harrison
Ford it wants to be there oh yeah
because he was like choked up at one
point you heard them screaming in
yelling for him he looks better at Han
Solo now than he was as Indiana Jones in
Crystal Skull I think that he's actually
gotten a little cooler looking as the
years ago I agree but fans were excited
to see it it was this big big moment
that the fans are gonna take forever
let's roll with you guys that I didn't
see much of because Tiffany and I were
inside most of the time yeah I like I
really wish we could have been out on
the streets mingling with the people
don't get upset I happen to be a genius
and movie special effects that's
his name is not cabbage it is I don't
think it's coming I'm gonna put you guys
in the heart of San Diego comic-con
right on the street Dan you got it you
have to keep the tractor co-op oh
because I'm gonna turn you into NBA
superstar Dwight Howard are you ready
yes yes yes cue the Sun hey everybody
I'm Tiffany Smith and we are here at San
Diego comic-con with Dwight Howard tower
are you excited to be here Dwight dan in
order for this to work you got to say
something but oh you want me to talk yep
okay okay really happy to be here Dan no
listen this is Dwight Howard talk yes I
have I think I'm doing a good job
oh he's electric me Dwight Howard what
are you so done no no it looks great oh
my god this is so stupid
I'm leaving no that was fun can we play
another game
yes man it's time to play a game and
this is the movie whisper the Star Wars
edition these two characters here are
gonna put on headphones they're gonna
listen to loud music so they can hear
anything and I'm just gonna whisper Star
Wars names they have to guess and
whoever gets the most right gets the
spin the winners wheel of winning I'm
definitely ready to go bid Fortuna
that's an obscure one yes kannada max
max max what's a Star Wars name of
thanks Max Kellerman I don't know you
look like you look like a minion
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations winners will of winning
that's what this is you get to spin it
whatever it lands on that's what you're
gonna do are you ready ready to clean my
winning you're gonna be able to rant for
ten seconds on anything you want so
everyone's little curious about been off
like it's Batman and the trailer came
out of Comic Con every was so excited we
see that he's in Metropolis you saved
the kitten I was like oh my god and then
gets on the elevator you realize that he
has to be Batman again it's so awesome I
realize all right that's gonna do it
guys thank you so much I think you give
a special thanks to our guest today dan
parole thank you so much for joining us
and while you're here make sure you guys
click Subscribe and download the brand
new Fandango movie clip tap on your
smartphone thank you for watching and
being part of the movie threesome Shane
[Music]